TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Deeplearn.js is an open source
WebGL accelerated JavaScript
library for machine
learning that
runs entirely in your
browser with no installation
and no back end.
Some cool screenshots and
links for getting started
are on the post linked
in the description below.
We recently added three
new subscription reports
to the subscriptions dashboard
in the Google Play Console.
They cover acquisition,
retention, and cancellations.
For more info on
these new features,
as well as our
updated best practices
to help you grow your
subscriptions business,
take a look at the post.
The next generation
Dex Compiler, D8,
is now available for preview
as part of Android Studio 3.0
beta release.
Compared to the
current DX compiler,
D8 compiles faster and
outputs smaller dex files
while having the same or
better app runtime performance.
Try it out with the
instructions on the post.
Developer Preview
5 of Android Things
is now available and is based on
the upcoming Android O release.
Details and links
are on the post.
Registration for the
2017 Firebase Dev Summit
is now open.
Please join us in
Amsterdam on October 31
for a day of talks, code
labs, and office hours.
For more details on what to
expect and a link to register,
head on over to the post.
The Cloud Speech
API now has features
that expand support
for long form audio
and further extend
our language support
to help even more
customers around the world.
Each of the updates is
detailed on the post.
We've updated Cloud
SQL for PostgreSQL
with 19 extensions
across 4 categories,
including better support
for geographic applications,
a variety of new data types,
and enhanced functionality
with new processing languages.
Links to more info
are on the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching this
week's episode of The Dev Show.
If you'd like to catch some
of our previous episodes,
they're right over here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]